hola bienvenidos a este especial de
emigrantes el programa semanal de france
24 sobre el éxodo nos saludan juliet
riaño
[Música]
sin opción y acosados por los conflictos
la guerra y la falta de oportunidades
miles de personas salen cada año desde
países del medio oriente áfrica y asia
en busca de un futuro mejor hacia los
paises de europa siendo el viaje por el
mar mediterráneo un camino peligroso
algunos migrantes prefieren tomar la
ruta de los balcanes un recorrido que
los llevó a cruzar por macedonia serbia
hungría y croacia hasta llegar a algunos
de los países de la unión europea esa
era la ruta principal sin embargo el
bloqueo con barreras físicas y un mayor
control fronterizo en dichos territorios
obligó a replantear el trayecto lo que
puso a bosnia herzegovina en el mapa de
los que buscan refugio desde entonces
bosnia se ha convertido en una especie
de cuello de botella para al menos
70.000 personas según cifras de acnur
que han buscado cruzar la frontera hacia
croacia un país que bloquea el tránsito
y que ha recibido un sinnúmero de
denuncias por el trato inhumano que
reciben los refugiados cuando son
interceptados por las autoridades
un equipo de france 24 viajó hasta ese
lugar
irene sabio visitó bosnia en específico
las regiones próximas a la frontera con
croacia desde allí nos entregó un
panorama más general de la situación de
los refugiados que nos encontramos en el
pueblo de bélica la ducha en el extremo
noroccidental de bosnia y herzegovina a
pocos poquísimos kilómetros de la
frontera con croacia territorio de la
unión europea es por esta zona que han
pasado una parte de los más de 70 mil
migrantes que han arribado a este país
desde 2018 en el intento de alcanzar el
corazón de europa a través de la ruta de
los balcanes la mayoría de estas
personas proceden de grecia el país que
el año pasado endureció su legislación
para obtener el estatus de refugiado
veo incesante de personas que la unión
europea ha estado intentando frenar e
incluso detener en medio de críticas de
ongs y agencias internacionales
humanitarias que denuncian violaciones
de derechos humanos cabe recordar que
entre 2014 y 2020 las autoridades
europeas le han entregado a croacia unos
54 millones de euros para reforzar su
control fronterizo y que otros países
como eslovenia y que se encuentran aquí
muy cerca de donde estábamos han
levantado vallas en el intento de
dificultar el paso de los migrantes por
esta región mientras que italia fue
recientemente condenada por un tribunal
de roma por devoluciones informales a
esta región a algo que los ha expuesto a
situaciones aún más extremas y también
dramáticas ese viaje hacia el corazón de
europa tuvo en el último año un bloqueo
adicional las restricciones fronterizas
causadas por la pandemia de ccoo y 19 y
el propio virus que ha afectado a los
refugiados en los centros de asilo
gosling herzegovina enfrenta a una de
las tasas más altas de contagios en los
países de los balcanes lo que lleva a
los servicios de salud a enfocar sus
esfuerzos en la población local la la
pandemia no ha mejorado la situación al
revés mientras realizamos este reportaje
bosnia y herzegovina un país todavía
duramente afectado por las cruentas
guerras balcánicas de los 90 y con altas
tasas de pobreza y de paro registraba un
significativo aumento en los contagios
por coronavirus una situación que
conllevó el confinamiento de algunos
centros para migrantes en una medida que
no ha sido bien vista por la población
que se encuentra en estos centros y que
ha interpretado esta decisión como un
intento un intento más de frenar su
viaje hacia europa además de ello hemos
sabido que las autoridades locales que
se ven desbordadas por esa situación y
que también culpan a la unión europea y
también al estado nacional de este país
es por las situaciones han decidido
limitar las actividades de las ongs que
operan en este territorio entregando
por ejemplo alimentos
pero pese a la situación son cada vez
más los migrantes que engrosan las
listas de llegada a bosnia y herzegovina
las autoridades nacionales recurren a
cuestionadas devoluciones informales y
otras medidas de disuasión para frenar
el flujo la situación es complicada en
la región y afecta especialmente la
salud mental de una población
extremadamente vulnerable la de los
menores migrantes que permanecen allí y
que incluso han sido víctimas del trato
de las autoridades fronterizas croatas
veamos más en el siguiente informe de
nuestra enviada especial a bosnia irene
sabio
en el aire
una choza abandonada en la frontera
entre bosnia y croacia el donde vive
esta niña de afganistán se llama tiza y
como miles de migrantes aquí su familia
viajó bosnia con el sueño de alcanzar a
un lugar seguro en la unión europea no
tuvieron éxito fueron deportados por la
policía croata decenas de veces en
ocasiones de manera violenta
existen víctimas de una tranca
bien
[Aplausos]
a tiza de 10 años ahora solo puede ver a
su mamá a través de una pantalla su
calvario empezó hace dos meses cuando
fue expulsada sola con su papá mientras
que su madre logró cruzar la frontera
[Música]
la situación es aún más difícil para la
pandemia del 19 que dificulta el trabajo
de las acciones que ayudan a los
migrantes malos protegidos no obstante
el impacto psicológico en las menores
también supone un reto en campamentos
como el de uxbal cerca de sarajevo
en ley
no está aquí
ella es una menor siria nacida en holmes
pasó por varios campamentos antes de
llegar a bosnia y guarda el anonimato
por razones de seguridad
estuviste 30 en the way
y ansiedad y depresión estos son algunos
de los síntomas que los expertos han
detectado time después muchos niños
viajan por mucho tiempo especialmente
los no acompañados y habitualmente eran
muy jóvenes cuando dejaron sus países de
origen y tienen malos recuerdos además
por situaciones que han visto en el
camino y también en el centro de ceder a
300 kilómetros de sarajevo algunos
cuentan que fueron víctimas de la
violencia de la policía croata es el
caso de estado le sentirán y de fe
cristiana que logra pasar la frontera
pero que fue forzada a regresar a bosnia
usted y nicolás director del consejo
danés para los refugiados en bosnia
según sus datos que lo hace afectó a 16
mil deportaciones informales en 2020
expulsando a 800 niños en el 60% de los
casos hubo violencia
a los propios menores son víctimas de la
violencia de las fuerzas del orden
croatas el juego así los migrantes
llaman la apuesta de cruzar a escondidas
la frontera entre bosnia y croacia un
juego roto para la infancia e inocencia
de estos menores que sin embargo los
cooperantes también describen como muy
resilientes
entre los refugiados que están parados
en voz y herceg obinna existe otro grupo
vulnerable hombres que llegaron desde
áfrica y medio oriente que huyeron de la
persecución por su orientación sexual
sin embargo se encontraron con una
frontera hacia europa difícil de cruzar
por lo que permanecen meses e incluso
años en bosnia un país donde aún los
derechos del colectivo lgtb son un tabú
with my world live
hay 6 games
hay un descampado en la periferia de
sarajevo es el lugar donde este
emigrante marroquí el gti se concede
unos momentos afectos al aire libre con
su novio muchos de marruecos donde las
relaciones entre personas del mismo sexo
están penalizadas y paso por turquía
ante llegar a bosnia quiere alcanzar la
unión europea pero con la frontera
cerrada su viaje se detuvo aquí donde
intentó integrarse no lo logró sufrió
acoso y discriminación
[Aplausos]
[Música]
mayer donde no es un país de siglo
incluso los pocos que deciden quedarse
encuentran dificultades
warburton mayor pero hunter like that
face entrevistamos a este solicitante de
asilo en una oficina de acnur por
razones de seguridad se escapó de irán
después de que su mujer denunciara su
homosexualidad
en el campamento teme por su vida duerme
separado del resto pero comparte
espacios con migrantes de países en los
que los homosexuales son perseguidos
evangelistas morgan courtney quien sigue
su caso de cerca nos explica que
peticiones de asilo como las de él no
son priorizadas y hay escasez de
alojamientos adecuados
este es el reto ahora mismo es que el
sistema está bastante sobrecargado por
eso hay grandes tiempos de espera para
soluciones de largo plazo y la
integración en el país
sánchez andraca drik añade que su
organización ha atendido a una decena de
emigrantes
que pidieron asilo quiero subrayar
además que hasta la fecha ninguna de
estas peticiones de asilo ha tenido unas
respuestas decepcionados muchos retoman
el camino hacia la unión europea
cuando yo
juanmi
incertidumbre marginación y soledad lo
empujaron a seguir con su viaje rumbo a
la unión europea sueña con casarse con
su novio y retomar sus estudios en
matemáticas
las autoridades estiman que unos seis
mil migrantes permanecen parados en
bosnia actualmente la situación para los
migrantes es crítica y muchos ni
siquiera logran presentar su solicitud
de refugio datos de acnur indican que en
2020 fueron registradas 244 peticiones
de asilo pero solo un paquistaní logró
que se le concediera el estatus hasta
que emigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]